la plage la plus proche est à plus de
300 km pourtant toute l'année depuis
2014 à la mode Beuvron on peut pratiquer
le beach tennis cette discipline a vu le
jour en Italie à la fin des années 70 et
dépend en France de la Fédération de
tennis un sport en plein essor qui se
joue en double avec un filet à un mètre
80 pour les hommes Victor le pratique
depuis 5 ans au sein de la team Sologne
le salle brésien est classé 97e joueur
français
les déplacements sont pas du tout les
mêmes ça ressemble au déplacement du
badminton dans le sable il faut être
beaucoup plus physique c'est beaucoup
plus intense que le tennis si on veut
prétendre à un très bon niveau il faut
savoir faire la différence entre le
beach tennis et le tennis qui est pas du
tout la même chose au niveau technique
déplacement physique préparation tout ça
ce week-end l'Open de France de
tennis se déroulait pour la troisième
année consécutive sous le grand manège
du Parc équestre de la mode Beuvron 170
équipes venues de toute la France et
réparties sur 24 terrains s'ils sont
affrontés
on est sur le plus haut grade de tournoi
en France ce qu'on appelle le bt2000
l'équipe gagnante marque 2000 points
pour le classement national et après on
classe les joueurs du premier au dernier
le numéro 1 c'est le numéro 1 français
loisirs de plage pour le grand public le
beach tennis est un sport exigeant et
qui possède ses propres règles il compte
39 000 pratiquants en France l'ont une
cinquantaine à Lamotte-Beuvron